[__] hates me
isn't does he say She [__] Hates Me
yeah I knew it that's I I know that kind
of stuff so it was nice
[Music]
wow that is so 90s what was that dude
yeah wow dude
drunk
[Music]
of like the Gucci place
Century City Mall some uh jewelry store
in Irvine I follow these accounts now on
Instagram it's what accounts like I
think one of them is called faces of
LAPD well another one is called I mean
they're just like random crime watch you
follow those yeah why because uh at
first I followed them because they were
like what's up with like the Homeless
Problem yeah yeah oh yeah that TV is not
on see all the encampments and [__]
um
and then I was just like
you know what now that I'm answering I'm
realizing I shouldn't
I don't even know if recording but I
might think we are
um we are
I shouldn't be following them they just
depressed me
yeah I follow some of those
but not but I don't
I don't like I I actually saw uh them
robbing stuff on the Gucci store and
under it there were only
comments like good for them oh my God
and I was like wait a minute what and I
kept scrolling and it was like hell yeah
[__] Gucci they deserve it dude people
just like what what this is a crime yeah
it was so odd people are so angry now
dude I know it's really weird right I
love seeing anybody or certainly any
Corporation but even people oh yeah yeah
just get [__] yeah any brand any any
kind of like person that's like quote
unquote on on top or not you know are
part of the one but at the same time
they go suck on the crank of Mattel all
right well we don't need to be
revisiting the crank of Midtown I'm
saying it's all of the same piece this
is episode what does it say Mike I'm 69
69 uh releasing oh yeah today and it is
uh Sunday and Sundays are for Lifeline
go sign up for our Lifeline luxury
patreon.com Lifeline luxury a new
episode is out right now Bing I am on
tour I'll be in uh I believe Irvine and
Brea and also um I will be in Charlotte
and Nashville and uh Knoxville and
Little Rock and Canada go to
chrisley.com for all that and uh if you
got a question hit the link in the
description below or get the or you can
call the the thing below call the
hotline on the link below
um
213-973-080
I love we love I particularly love
um uh follow-up videos yeah you like
that those are fun those are funny to me
because I like to catch up with the
people that we talked to so throw us
some of that and uh you wanna you want
the 101 want the one on one with me I
mean like it's a fight you you want to
do one-on-one Mano Amana with me go to
mattdelia.com and book
it now had some heavy duty sessions the
other day you got heavy stuff come on
and get it you got light stuff come on
and get it this is ice natalia.com
that's ice and uh you want the merch go
to
lifelinemerch.com and buy every single
piece
um so yeah well that's too much about it
that crime is happening all over the
place all over the place and everywhere
it's pretty it's pretty weird cities are
just like they're in trouble I know it's
looking better and better to live off
the grid dude I'm the Unabomber it's
looking better and better to live out in
the the nothingness that's the thing
though I don't want to live in the
middle of nowhere I like cities dude I
know I like cities to be good but then
it's like uh you know I want to take my
son for a haircut and I still got a
haircut too you know we both got
haircuts and like there was just a crazy
two crazy people that were just like
walking by and I was like oh come here
buddy come closer and that doesn't
happen in the wilderness but you gotta
watch out for Bears right so there's an
in between you know there's an image
very urban areas in the very rural areas
but then those are where there's or
crazy people and that suburbs kind of
suck in their own way so where are we
also suburbs are all the same yeah what
are we supposed to do
I don't know man what do we got where do
we go either live in the wilderness
then you gotta like know how to be with
wild Guys Guns big guns you got to know
everybody live in the cities with small
guns
right in the city like this
in the cities yeah or the big ass rifles
in the wilderness in case bears come
yeah did you see that one picture of
that bear where there's a picture of a
bear and they don't know if it's a
person or a bear
and they thought it was fully a person
in America and it's a bear it's a bear
wow it's at the zoo they thought it was
a uh like they were yeah people thought
the zoo was trying to pull right right
right not like a prank yeah bears are
bears bears do stand up like that though
and and I guess they wave right yeah
that's crazy make it bigger that is
absolutely Bonkers I got a buddy who uh
that is so crazy that bear is just like
suck
but also of course it's not a person no
I know of course it's not a person but
you think that's a person where was this
China that's because the Chinese were
like oh China wait a minute wait a
minute a lot of Chinese people are like
wait a minute what the heck they do that
all the time wait I don't understand
they do that a lot China I'm racist
um
also yeah do they think meerkats are
small people I don't know what what does
a meerkat look like like a [__]
oh like a little person yeah like no no
really little like a miniature person
like this like super like a small yeah
uh oh yeah they got people things going
on yeah yeah maybe they could be like a
baby or something like a skinny baby
yeah yeah skinny babies so um
yeah it's obviously a bear that's
actually stupid now that I see the whole
video it's obviously when it sits down
it's such a bear right and being there
you'd even know even more right yeah
because you'd be like oh that's so heavy
the way he sat down that's definitely a
bear I would be so mad right there if a
person could do that they'd be rich from
impersonating Bears because they're so
they'd be so good at it yeah I would be
like if I was there I would get this
sense I'd be like dude
you're all probably you know what I can
tell and I'm already pissed off you're
all thinking that maybe this is a person
in there and it's [__] not I'm gonna
tell you right now did you see the guy
who got uh I don't like this they're
trying to make headlines out of the guy
who's trying to be like a border collie
oh yeah dude that is
so Japanese you know what I'm saying
like that is only a thing that would
happen and did it happen in Japan yeah
oh wow they don't even know who it is
the annoying thing about that is they're
like man paid twenty thousand dollars to
transform to a border collie whatever it
is but it's it you there it's not he
didn't do surgery he just got a costume
no yeah
so it's like it's a what's weird about
the costume is that it's really good and
some moments and then some moments it
looks just like a person in a dog
totally it's really good if he doesn't
move if he makes some movements he knows
how to do it but then if he makes other
movements you're like oh that's so dumb
it's a person in there what's going on
yeah also what kind of weird
it's a kink you're a weirdo it's always
sexual is it
I read about it was his life on look he
spent 22 Grand to become a rough collie
dog but he didn't become the dog is the
thing I know but people click more when
they say I know that I don't like that
[__] with the media guy buys dog costume
that's that's the thing but it is an
insanely good dog costume The Still of
the [__] bust of the dog is unreal
yeah
it just looks where does he look out of
it the eyes I don't know I don't know
anything that's the other thing if he's
looking out of the eyes I buy it a
little more if he's not looking under
the eyes and they're like coming out of
the mouth like you might work out if you
might as well work at [__] Disneyland
dude yeah right yeah you're not a dog no
you're not you're a dude with a [__]
face in a dog in a fake dog's mouth well
you're not a dog under any Circle you're
not a dog period yeah
Toco you know Toco dude look at this see
that's not a dog no that's not a dog
that looks like a dog it looks like an
old dog crazy messed up
where is the guy I don't know
I do not get it
you know what that's amazing I take
everything back what I said I don't
think it's cool it looks like a dog dude
that's king that's that's Kink right
there he's in a cage you know
so you think he's got just a big boner
in there no I no I think it's a mentally
sexual thing anything anytime someone
does something that's super weird it's a
kink okay hey with their identity
specifically or just super weird in
general
with their identity and good
your hair's looking good what is it out
of 10.
uh
eight or nine got a haircut today with
my son that's why oh dude haircuts never
make your hair look good I know but you
know what it is no one did I know but
you know what tomorrow it's going to
look all [__] up I bet oh really it
has to grow into the [__] upness and
then get good oh I see what you're
saying when you cut your hair it looks
terrible
or it looks banging and then you wash it
and it looks hard yeah yep yeah yep all
right that's good and I'm right about
that that's good um all right well let's
get into some stuff on Lifeline guys so
far
hey Chris and Matt I'm wondering what
you guys think about this television
somebody will pop into your life when
you least expect it I've been single
pushing four years now open your
creative girls talk to girls uh in that
in that time span but I won't settle uh
maybe I'm too picky maybe that's my own
fault oh okay I'm walking through
um I hear this from a lot of my friends
that are in relationships and uh I don't
know what to think of it uh do I put
myself out there maybe do the dating
apps I'm not too active on social media
or do I keep my head down focus on my
career and working out let me know what
you guys think
first of all open your mouth a little
bit more
not just so we can understand you more
but so that you're more inviting when
you open your mouth like that it seems
like you're over it like you said it
might not it might not be yeah it might
not be it might be one of the reasons
why he's not dating yeah work on the
vibe you're throwing out if you open
your mouth a little more you'd probably
be in love at this point yeah also
you're like
a good looking guy yeah hey good looking
guy so since you're a good looking guy
open your mouth just a tiny bit more
what I don't get is uh
why did he sneak in the working out
thing
I don't think he snuck it in I think he
just didn't it doesn't Lane that it was
out is not a thing to be like yeah dude
I want a chick but I'm working out no no
no no no no no no no no unless you're a
bodybuilder and that's your job I think
I think what that was was just like a
slip of
casual familiarity instead of like like
he shouldn't have been that specific
about that you think so I think he was
just like that's what I like to do and
he didn't go down a whole list he was
just like working out and then you don't
think he was like man these [__]
always getting to getting they're
blocking my gains no no no I don't think
so you don't think so no no I don't
think so but if you win if he was then
you got to get your [__] together
because that's stupid yeah nobody has to
work out so much they can't go on dates
right
um yeah I don't know man I mean I
[__] work out pretty hard unless
you're an actual bodybuilder yeah if
your bodybuilder cool but if your body
builder that's so weird but yeah yeah
don't do that uh go back in time and
don't get into the into the business of
bodybuilding who do bodybuilders date
dude bodybuilders yeah
they got to be gay all of them right
because they look at their bodies so
much they're just like I got a big
Counterpoint to that Arnold
Schwarzenegger yeah that guy's the least
gay he just was like back in the day he
was just literally just like swinging
his dick around putting it inside I like
Arnold Schwarzenegger is is he not gay
he's not gay dude the whole thing he had
a he had a illegitimate sign up I made
remember I just found that out okay but
here's the thing you cut me off and say
you know that as if we're just two
people talking in a room we are this is
a show oh you know why wouldn't I say
that it's a podcast it's not like
because it's like you're cutting me off
and you want to break up saying it no no
I don't want you to not stop saying it I
don't want you to stop saying it okay
it's so weird we just talked about this
though yeah we did but we did
um oh wait what no we just talked about
on Golden hour it's so weird what him
having the legitimate we talked about
that specific thing that you do though
oh yeah we always talk about that
because you get you you don't like when
I do that but but he did he had an
illegitimate kid but then also you know
you don't think he's ever porked a dude
ever that I don't I don't know that that
means you're gay or what no I don't
think you think you can have sex with
one guy and not be gay
I guess yeah it depends on if you're gay
do you like to have sex with men are you
attracted to men then you are gay so I
was talking to a guy once
I knew him I know him okay and he was
like I made a joke I was like ah man
maybe it's because you're gay and he was
like no no way my I'm not guy he's uh
Australian he's like nah not gay not me
and I was like what a weird reaction
yeah I mean that just makes us think you
know what and I said why do you say it
like that and he said because my
long time ago I tried it once
and I just didn't like it full I fully
endorse that guy's take on so do I okay
yeah but also is he gayer than me who's
never done it it's it there's no way of
knowing it's a subjective thing it's a
spectrum he knows you know but I would
say that I fully buy that yeah trying it
and realizing yeah no I totally think
that you cannot be gay and do that I
have another friend that black people
don't black people be like yo that's my
gay yeah well cultures are different you
know they'd be like yo dog that's gay as
[__] to even be in a room with another
dude but there are gay black people you
know that right you ever been to the
bank and there's only been one one other
person there I won't even go in man
because I only [__] chicks right
um there's no gay black people there are
gay black people there are they are and
when they're gay they're really gay you
know what I mean I see like Billy what's
that guy's name Billy crudup
yeah
um
no no yeah Billy that guy Billy with all
the space or is he just because
sometimes he'll just be like he's just
people like that will just be like I'm a
woman actually um oh oh I think he's
just a a gay man yeah I think
um oh he is
uh I got broken about when you said it
um wait wait wait
I'm gonna fart what were we just talking
about though I was gonna say he's Arnold
Schwarzenegger ah
damn
um yeah so I I don't know man I don't
know if that's I don't know but here
about the guy about this guy's advice
yeah dude
I don't I I hear you and I I get it and
I know it's a thing that a lot of people
are wondering you look young I don't
think you have anything to worry about
in terms of like a ticking clock or
anything but here's the thing about
dating things may dry up here's the
thing about dating or not dating
you either want to
if you don't want to date yeah then
don't if you do want to date then do it
it's as simple as that yeah totally like
he said he's been single for a while
that's how making you feel good then
stay single these kinds of guys are just
like dude you haven't met someone yet
exactly like if you met some someone you
like trust me dude you'll know because
your life will be in shamble they'll
[__] ruin your life because women
ruin your lives you know what I'm saying
do men ruin women's lives
women and men ruin each other's lives
because they don't they're not alike yes
okay this is a gay Partners ruin each
other nope no they just [__] and chill
what about okay game women too no they
ruin each other's lives they do oh yeah
see I have my sense is too many feelings
my sense is first of all that let all
lesbians hate me that's the number one
so I don't know that many lesbians I
want to be friends with lesbians
but uh lesbians seem to me to generally
be the most even killed and and
generally happiest inside relationships
on the surface that's what I'm saying I
don't know what they're like at home but
like at home the vibe I get the sense I
get yeah that guy's not a lesbian though
so that doesn't apply no no no no uh two
two a man and a woman together ruin each
other's lives two men do not ruin each
other's lives two women together ruin
each other's lives it's like I'm happy
people or gay men the only Happy People
are gay men yes
the only Happy People are gay men this
is not at all scientific I don't know if
I believe for me you but I I believe
that it's possible that it's true yep
that's why they're always dancing and
doing parades oh do you know who's not
in those [__] dancing parades
lesbians
they're not there dude interesting
interesting they're trying to buy
[__] clothes with pockets on them
you know what's that joke about lesbians
the the second date they're getting a
U-Haul I mean I just sold the joke after
but like there's some joke about like
lesbians like settle down like that oh
really yeah yeah
um I don't know what it's okay that I
said that because
I heard a lesbian make that joke okay so
it's not me making sure the expensive
lesbians
and I don't know they never said that
I'm just repeating a lesbian no I don't
I don't know I've never repeated that's
what I do it's my main thing I repeat
lesbians wow that's good okay let's do
another one
know the exact location of somewhere
or have they have to tell you the exact
location of somewhere in order for you
to get the story but it has nothing to
do with the application
like they'll be like oh yeah I was down
uh oh man by the turnpike over there you
know where that is and then I'm like nah
so they proceed to tell you try to get
you exactly where it is you know take
this street down there blah blah blah 20
minutes of trying to find the exact
coordinates once they do you're like oh
yeah whatever over there oh yeah well
I just found this place next door so I
don't know it'll just make no sense to
the point where you didn't have to know
the exact location you could have just
said it right that's annoying so uh I
don't know tell me what's up with that
guys dude dude I I just I just had a
revelation I didn't know white people
did that but I do that I don't do that
and when people do that yeah because
people do do that I say it doesn't
matter maybe you're black I gotta I say
it doesn't matter cuz dude there are
people I have a friend that will do that
and it's on
believable I might do that [__] I'm
worried and I say I can't believe you
haven't said the thing yet yeah you're
only telling me places
is he white yeah okay well then he's
dude it's unbelievable and that guy also
will like show me a picture of like
straight up his like of him somewhere in
Hollywood
and he's done this before he showed me a
selfie
and I say
what's that and he says dude you don't
remember that picture oh just of him and
I said of of your face right yeah and he
was like come on and I was like he was
like to tell me when he took it and sent
it to me I was like
I don't remember that and he was like
how do you not remember that what and
then I say are you asking me why I don't
remember when you sent me this selfie
two years ago right and then he gets it
okay oh yeah but and then I'm like stop
this sounds like a weird guy oh he is
weird but he will he'll be like you know
the place the thing so I was at this
place today you know I've done the thing
you know it no yeah it's not the thing
next thing I'll do no oh yeah there's
and they can stop playing you walk to
the door okay yeah I found twenty
dollars there why don't you just say Oh
I thought 20 today not because you're
equipped with this why don't you
just say yes you know even if you don't
so he doesn't do it oh yeah I know
exactly what that is keep going because
I don't well I don't want a lot you
don't want a bat you don't want to bend
I don't want to bend I don't want to
give him that okay well that's that's
you change I'm not changing this is your
thing but now this guy's got me worried
that I think maybe I do that you think
you do that like what like what's a
version of how you do that
I just think I might be geographically
like
Geographic Centric about my stories
where I'm like I need the people to know
you maybe do that a little bit Yeah do I
I don't do that I mean that's why I was
laughing I was like [__] do I do that uh
anyway the answer is I don't know why
white people do that but that's really
really really funny
yeah that is funny you know what I mean
yeah
uh but I can't help you with that it
sucks if we do it if I do it it's I have
an answer what can I say don't hang out
with white people only hang out with
your kind oh
I don't think that's the greatest yeah
but it's not though I'm saying white
people do that and they shouldn't be
doing that they shouldn't but you know
what we all have our philosophy come on
lights
ah come on whites be more vague yeah
don't worry so much black people don't
get they're not specific
white people are so specific they're not
specific about location or they're not
specific they're not specific period in
stories when they tell stories bro
ah I'm a white guy yes ask me how I've
been
have you been
I have a pretty good I guess I really
kind of can't complain I mean it's
[__] hot out okay I'm a black guy
okay ask me how I've been hey how you
been
all right okay I'm I'm starting you know
what I'm saying I do know what you're
saying yeah
um
that's interesting um both of you guys
are opening my mind right now there you
go
um to your to the caller the caller
inner guy uh I don't know why but that's
very funny and thanks for bringing it to
my attention
now I won't do it especially I won't do
it around black people
because then I'll be like why the [__]
they'll be like why the [__] is this guy
doing that and I want to avoid that I'm
a white guy yeah I know ask me how my
friend Rob has been how's your friend
Rob been how's Rob been uh he's been
okay you know I haven't seen him in a
bit
um but last time I saw him he's good you
know he's got these guys kids and [__]
so uh it's been cool you know I met I
met one of his kids once he was at the
park and we were there too uh but he
seems good he's he looks good you know
he's getting older but he looks good and
now you're Rebecca now I'm black guy
asked me uh how
Darnell is what about Rob
well I'm a black guy now no no no no no
black people white people can know the
same people I'm gonna ask you about Rob
all right how's Rob been
man
I don't know oh and he knows
like he's withholding yeah it's like I'm
not ain't snitching like oh oh wow ax
Rob that's very different
okay okay I mean all right I don't even
know what Darnell is up to okay
all right yeah I mean I don't know if
that's all that's true but that guy's
that guy's probably right I don't know
how right you are you know what I'm
saying you know what I mean
I mean I think I'm right I know that I
know that real well let's go to the next
one
oh I can't remember I got it I got it I
got it trying to court a quote nervous
girl gonna try and keep this condensed
as possible while still including all of
the Deets well you failed at that I met
a girl maybe six months ago while she
was working front desk in a building
that I've been do multiple times to do
HVAC repairs in the first time I saw her
we were giving each other eyes like
crazy wise I doubt it I introduced
myself and gave her my number on a piece
of paper she seemed excited about it no
text a couple weeks later I'm back for
another repair and she's clearly happy
to see me she asked how I've been right
away and told me it's good to see me I
asked her why no text and she tells me
she's nervous I get her number I text
her no text back so I text again a week
later and I get a high sorry I'm a bad
texter I pretty much give up at this
point now I work for another company
these days so I haven't seen her in four
months about four months my old
co-worker goes for repair and said that
she was asking about me and told them
that she lost my number how do I
approach a girl who's clearly interested
to some degree but is allegedly nervous
life rips thanks that's weird let me let
me just let me just look
I don't like this I don't like having to
say this I don't like that it's true
it just is true
she doesn't like yeah but then why did
she ask how the friend was at the I
didn't think I did think that because
she's nice
yeah okay you're probably right being
too nice unfortunately some and this
actually is another unfortunate Theory
Sometimes women actually have to be too
nice no no no that is especially if you
feel like working in subscribers of
course of course of course she can't be
shitty of course you're a [__] killer
affects you but like yeah you might kill
women have to worry about that yeah
exactly of course so like look no
offense to you I'm sure you're a great
dude my sense is she doesn't yeah really
like you I would say that's almost
positive she thinks you're a good dude
yeah yeah she just she likes you as a
human yep but she doesn't want to date
you that's not into getting yeah and
guess what that's okay yeah oh yeah yeah
guess what there's gonna be other women
that do want to date you uh-huh okay yep
so everybody's happy everybody's
everybody everything's okay there's some
women that love HVAC guys I mean I bet
there's women out there that have a
fetish about HVAC guy yep like the dog
thing like uh like the pool guy thing
the pool guy I think it's mostly Pool
Guys and not HVAC I bet there's two guys
are oh the heater's broken oh let's get
him inside his butt
I would say pool guys are probably on
the whole definitely hotter than
anything yeah yeah yeah because your
pool guy is at least like probably in
the Sun a lot it looks healthier and
he's got to be a little bit active
fishing the stuff out of the pool also
yeah he's got his shirt off more
um but HVAC guys can be totally fat and
just be like you need another part right
yeah I'm trying to think of HVAC guys
I've known I know a few what do they
look like
uh they're either old white
old white or just like Mexican
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I found that problem
you know they're like that okay and
you're like what and they're like you
need and then they might as well say
anything because you don't know what
they're saying yeah in my experience so
how much it's gonna be and they say 900
HVAC guys okay HVAC has in my experience
always Russian
you're going to have to yeah yep the guy
who installed my HVAC recently Russian
brought two guys when he installed it
both Russian
how long have you had this here
uh yeah how long have you had this unit
I don't know 18 months something like
that ah
the the problem with this kind is
um
that is what it is if it isn't warranty
but it should last for 10 years uh I'm
going to take a look uh inside of this
uh different part of what I didn't look
at the first time and I'm going to see a
little more detail on what is going on
you may be so specific this guy's even
Russians are even more specific than
regular white guys yeah yeah you may
need a certain part I'd be I'd be give
me half hour
come back okay he's holding something
okay uh yes I found the problem you need
this uh you need one of these uh it's
not under warranty so you're going to
have to I have one in my I may have one
in my right always always I may have one
in my truck let me check
okay he comes back yes I have do you
want to do right say how much is it how
much is it 350 220 yeah three you want
me to do it yeah okay plus server plus
labor is going to be 410 or something
yeah okay okay
yeah they're always rushing right I also
had a guy come uh try to fix my
okay so two two times in a span of one
month my dishwasher broke I get a guy to
come out the first guy comes out he's
rushing he is
petrified of my dog what my dog for
those who don't know is like 30 pounds
and yeah couldn't hurt you know even if
she wanted to uh and I I laughed I
didn't even mean to be a dick I was like
uh
come on yeah yeah yeah yeah but what do
you mean petrified like do what he's
doing he okay well I don't want to stand
up but he was standing up and he was
like
oh dog is no no no oh oh wow okay very
he goes very scared oh oh wow yeah I
feel bad I was like oh [__] and I
laughed a little but I was like I didn't
want to laugh yeah yeah yeah yeah
this guy's got clearly who knows
something terrible yeah yeah this whole
family got [__] by a different dog
different times the dog family came over
and [__] his human family dogs keep
coming over [__] my family when I
grow up they [__] everybody in my family
different dogs crazy I don't want to be
around dogs Russian dogs by the way you
need this part the the whole thing with
uh they got toxic
they got a toxic what's the thing in
Russia
the toxic waste oh they have the the
Chernobyl yeah
they came over and [__] his family
um but no but then he comes fixed it two
three minutes okay okay did something I
could have done but I was like ah sure
yeah and he's like 200 yeah yeah no he
was like just the labor fee that's it
just the charge for coming out and
visiting right then uh however many
weeks later same problem same company
different guy comes out also Russian
he's working on it for like three or
four hours at the very end he finally is
like I know what the problem is the main
frame is yeah it's got this fried thing
in his hand right it's just like I think
he did that you know I mean like I think
well how big is the thing he's holding
like like that he should have seen it
within four hours for sure right so he's
lying yeah right okay and so and but no
then I'm like ah so you can't do
anything there's no you need to replace
the whole thing unless you this uh out
of warranty yeah yeah yeah and then and
then he's like it's out of uh C and he
goes online he's like shows it doesn't
even get made anymore it's been fine you
know right and I'm like okay how much do
I owe you and he says just the amount to
come
but I did not fix
I did not do not that did not fix so
then what then I just gave him the same
amount of money the first guy came for
it was like the most honest company ever
dude okay so he didn't fix didn't fix it
so then what though I have to get a new
dishwasher oh but I think he broke it
but it was already broken but but but
the first guy fixed it dude easily
um yeah he didn't break I don't know
because I wasn't looking over his
shoulder you don't know because you're
not a [__] dishwasher also right well
nobody is a dishwasher well no there are
dishwashers in actual in Japan uh no no
no like I mean
in diners there's like hey I got it you
know oh people yeah
you're not a dishwasher or an HVAC guy
or a guy who fixes dishwasher no I'm not
he was just like this after three hours
he was just like this
[Laughter]
like this
uh sir I found problem sorry this here
is is broken and they don't make them
anymore
in all honesty though I thought he was
trying to scam me and I was like all
right how much would it cost to get a
new one he goes I don't do
so I was like oh you really maybe you're
being honest you know
he's probably as [__] tired he's like
I want to go home yeah I think that was
probably yeah yeah wow all right next
one
hey what's up Matt and Chris uh huge fan
of you guys Chris I saw you in New York
a couple months ago that was your best
show yet that I've seen you yeah and
Matt love everything that you're doing
man cool
um my name is Luke I'm from New York and
my question is about my work I do photo
and video and oftentimes on shoots
people will make awkward comments about
their weight or their appearance but
most of the centers about their weight
um so a woman recently on a shoot came
storming over to me she was like way in
the background of a photo but she's like
I know you did not just take a photo of
my big fat ass what and I'm like what
yeah
um and then you know people will be like
make me look 10 years younger and 10
pounds lighter that's not a thing if the
camera adds 10 pounds you must have had
seven or eight cameras on me so the
comments are wide-ranging wow and but
the theme is that I have no idea what to
say to everyone yeah yeah yeah
um definitely I want to keep it somewhat
professional at least yeah
um don't want to just slam people into
Oblivion but looking forward to
um hearing what you guys have to say
thanks so much I mean they they deserve
to be slammed into Oblivion you wouldn't
want to the camera has 10 pounds you say
how many cameras did you eat dude
um I don't like it made me look thin is
I if I was a cameraman and some fat
person said that I would yeah
there would be a light I would be so an
Ang I would be so I would be fired
that's what he's trying to move yeah so
let's okay let's try to avoid that first
make me look thin oh man
no just be like lose weight right be
thin yeah I know dude you know how I can
take a picture to me
you know how I can take a really great
picture of you when you look really thin
lose 10 pounds
because then you'll be really thin like
you don't what you need to what you need
to say is I'm only gonna be able to take
a picture of what you really look like
that's all I can do because that's
that's what I do
my camera doesn't do magic tricks I
can't manipulate an image just by taking
it right picture right what you can say
is okay well maybe after when I treat
them I can do something but like I don't
know what that's so crazy that someone
would have the gall to say that they're
basically just being like I'm fat
what are you supposed to say does if
somebody comes up to you and they say
I'm fat what are you supposed to say
well yeah you you go yeah
yeah but it's okay right so how what's
the what's the his answer version of
yeah but it's okay how about like this
uh somebody says oh made me look thinner
it'd be like
uh yeah they say the camera adds 10
pounds that's why I I'm behind the
camera I don't want to be looking all
fat and [__] anyway this is the first
part was kind of all right actually I
don't know something like that you know
maybe uh
oh geez um but you know what he should
always say what
I got it just I got I got it yeah yeah
you know I got it trust me you're gonna
look beautiful exactly you're gonna look
great yeah that's what he said you know
that he already says that you look great
though anymore about it it was great God
damn look at those titties
uh if he already says if he already says
that yeah then he's already doing it
right you don't want here's what you
don't want to be honest for you don't
want to be honest because then you won't
get hired again because people will talk
[__] about you and never recommend you
if you're a professional never be honest
yeah basically yeah so but what was the
thing about the fat ass I know you
didn't take a picture of my fan like
what I know you just didn't take a
picture of my fat ass what does that
mean though
I don't know maybe he was like a wedding
photographer like under her skirt no no
no no no no she's saying fat ass not fat
ass like oh like a descriptor of herself
yeah okay but maybe he was like a
wedding guy and he just took a picture I
know you did a bit of my fat ass what
you look great yeah Boogie Nights we
just came we dug came to party I'm just
a wedding photographer yeah you know
yeah
yeah why you look great no it was great
or or just no you weren't in that one do
that no you're fat ass wasn't in that
one I mean just be like dude you weren't
in it you weren't in that one no let me
see it
looks at my fat asses in there
oh I see yeah I'm saying that's tough
yeah oh I have no idea what I'm taking a
picture of I'm in the zone baby
oh yeah I'm in the zone baby I'm in the
zone to ruin it definitely don't say
that I'm in the zone baby you know I'm
in Powers Austin [__] power I'm in
the zone Church keep posing wow
yeah yeah I don't know man that you're
screwed though exactly yeah I I like
like you look beautiful you look great
you know
but you don't want to like
yes well you don't want to sexually
harass right well God damn I mean top to
bottom you look unreal you should do
Playboy no what you should say is no
it's going to be great I promise you
it's going to be great yep that's what
you say put make them believe that you
know something they don't know
just to get out of the moment yeah
that's it you know you don't get how
this goes I got it right because in a
way that's nicer than that you know what
doll
listen to me baby wow already would be
fired I'm gonna make you look great just
like this I'm gonna make you look great
just
I'll delete that one
yeah yeah yeah just just make them think
you know more about photography than
they do right what you do exactly but
make them know that in that moment and
then but make that
use that to make them stop worrying yeah
yeah like no trust me I know what I'm
doing yeah there you go I got this one
yeah I got it don't worry it's gonna be
great yeah anything you don't want we'll
get rid of yeah like whatever there it
is you know yeah
what's up guys love the show
um basically I have a friend who
recently started smoking cigarettes like
social situations and like at parties
and stuff
um and it's kind of like concerning
because he really likes doing it I mean
like obviously because it's cigarettes
right but I don't want it to develop
into like an addiction or he starts
doing it alone and then like relying on
it okay action so I guess my question is
like how should I keep an eye on it from
like a like a distance kind of but not
be overbearing and
you know butt my head into something
that's not my business I just don't want
to watch my friend get addicted to
cigarettes because that's sad uh also
how [__] is it to like have too many
groceries in your hand and then try to
open a door with your pinky and kind of
have to like oh yeah extreme the
definition yeah reach it and then like
grab that's the maximum [__] thanks man
love you I mean dude I'm gonna say about
this yesterday I can't I actually can't
believe people [__] smoke right now I
can't believe people why can't you
believe it
there's so much
knowledge about it how bad it is for you
like I I I do get why people do
do drugs recreationally but smoking is
like the thing that if you do it pretty
much you just do it all the time I mean
I guess there's people who only smoke
when they drink yeah they're those
people yeah for sure but that's not what
he's talking about what he's talking
about is people who say like he's
talking about for now that is what is
right right yeah but the people who
smoke
all the time
unless they've been doing it for you
know 20 years yeah like now it's crazy
you're saying how could you start yeah
kind of or in the past few years yeah I
mean I love smoking so like I totally
get it but I agree that scars to smoke
now yeah
is a questionable weird thing it's just
and here's the other thing back in the
day like even when we were kids
even after that smoking still had like a
Sheen of coolness yeah yeah it doesn't
anymore no no it's so [__] annoying
any time that I've that I've gone back
to smoking because after quitting I'd
like pick it back up I'm always like oh
God I don't I don't want people to know
I don't want to be out in public doing
it I'm aware of being around strangers
like none no part of me is like yeah
it's not badass anymore it was badass in
the 90s and now it's just like ew that
guy's [__] weird well it's gross it
smells bad everyone knows how bad it is
for you and like it's it's just a bad
habit say that no but that's the this is
what is it the [__] 90s yeah but this
is what I was gonna say hey go listen to
[__] Limp Biscuit the more you do
stupid [__] wow the more you do stuff
like that
hey what's puddle of Mud up to
hey recite their lyrics all of them
because you know all of them all stupid
[__] [__] let me borrow The
Offspring CD yeah yeah yeah hey dude
isn't it crazy that new rapper Eminem is
white you douche [__] idiot so mean
uh that's the problem though with with
stuff like that you want to be careful
to not
be the cop because that way stop smoking
not be a narc I'm just kidding you know
about Eminem
you don't want
to be like that because some people
that'll make them want to do it more
well that's ultimately why people smoke
at this point
[__] them I'm doing it right [__] mom
and dad or you know what I mean you're
saying I don't care about my health I'm
badass well no people are addicted to
smoking no now but I'm saying start
start yeah yeah yeah yeah no yeah you
probably yeah yeah the addiction I I
mean like I bet it it actually I don't
smoke I've never smoked
I'm telling you it looks awesome not the
look of it I bet it's so nice to have a
thing where you're like I'm gonna go
take a break and smoke this [__]
cigarette dude I love that yeah but I
don't do it because I know it's bad yeah
but man I would love to I would love to
do that well that is to start smoking
that is the thing that when you are a
smoker that is the appeal and that is
the hardest thing at least when I was a
smoker when I when I've been a smoker
it's hardest to let go of um where
you're just what do you do with the time
you're going to be out not just that but
it's also like you you end up dividing
up your moments throughout the day yeah
bookending it with cigarettes like after
you eat you smoke oh you know you're
doing it before bed you smoke [__] like
smokers are so [__] annoying dude but
to non-smokers they're crazy annoying
yeah yeah because it's like where is he
yeah right we were just eating yeah
we're having a conversation where the
[__] did he go well you know whose fault
that is all the people who complained
about all the smoke inside the
restaurant and in my lungs well I know I
actually don't my kid's gonna inhale
this thing right from the guy over there
I don't think it's their fault I don't
care I don't care if there's smoke in
cigarette and in uh restaurants I don't
I honestly don't either but I actually
do think it shouldn't be around kids
though kids because they don't [__] them
up real way worse than kids yeah yeah
but if they're all adults and you're out
it's 10 p.m I don't give a [__] if
someone lights up I don't give a [__]
yeah dude I remember when I I smoked
when the Bloomberg was mayor in New York
the the law was enacted that you can't
smoke in bars and restaurants
they came around at midnight with
ashtrays at the bar I was at the day
that the thing before everybody put them
out and if you were still smoking they
had made you leave whoa is that weird to
the next day yeah it is very weird but I
guess they were worried that people were
going to be giving citations that very
moment wow yeah
that was a really weird experience
actually yeah that is weird too because
I remember when it happened and you were
just and you were you not you but one
was just like wow they're really getting
rid of smoking in New York yeah because
I bleed New York you know what I mean in
New York and I was just like that's the
[__] lifeblood of New York is just
smoking inside bars and restaurants and
I was like how am I going to change
because of this because my home where I
bleed right is going to be starkly
different right right yeah well no but
yeah but I still believe New York you
know cool man I still kind of like New
York I feel it so you got through it my
soul my soul is in New York and my heart
is in New York and I believe New York
honestly my blood my heart my soul a lot
of my body parts are in New York if I'm
honest wow uh how do you live I guess
physically here in New York but partly
heart my blood my soul my mind my legs
my feet my hands my head and my eyes and
nose and mouth neck and all kind of the
Torso that's all in New York oh okay
[__] love New York man yeah cool man
smells like piss though dude everywhere
I don't like going back to New York
anymore it smells like piss I don't like
being in New York and there's also a guy
I used to love New York you land in New
York and you go to New York and when you
get near your hotel there's always some
guys what
I don't know if he's talking to me or
not no you're outside oh okay yeah I
mean a bunch of trash I hate being like
this but New York isn't cool to be in
anymore well everything's all uh careful
square feet New York Times Square of
five yeah not there are certain sections
honestly that my soul still lives in
though hey man you know enough of that
okay there are certain sections that I
still kind of feel my heart is involved
in and I bleed there all right I've lost
a lot of blood
[Laughter]
such a health hazard to go to New York
man there's still certain pockets in New
York that I still go there and just I
bleed there like I just [__] there
are some Pockets like just beautiful
[__] true New York Parts where I just
go and I just start I just bleed [__]
everywhere man just like just empty out
like I'm I'm in so much trouble yeah he
ended up in a coma last time I went to
Hell's Kitchen I went I was in Hell's
Kitchen and I was just I started
bleeding and my heart was there and I
was just my soul was there and my I was
bleeding all over the place and everyone
was like oh no and I finally I woke up
in the hospital sounds really bad yeah I
probably shouldn't go back yeah
all right next one yep
hi Chris and Matt my question is um in
regards to my guy best friend and my
cousin who was a female they are
roommates and
um they're friends because of me and
they live together because of me I hope
this situation up so there's like just a
little backstory there
um
my guy best friend has owed my cousin
months and months and months of rent
since 2021 pretty much
um it's a lot of money you live in New
York City oh New York City months and
months and months since 2021 yeah
yeah months and months a month I know
how much it is how long it's been going
on and I have stayed silent for over a
year about it there you go over yourself
and I guess my question to you guys is
should I get involved
the reason why I would I would get
involved is because my cousin is the
sweetest nicest person you will ever
meet
with that she is incredibly
non-confrontational
um it's weighed on her so much mentally
that she now needs to seek professional
help
the situation and that kills me so you
know I should I should I reach out
should I insert myself finally and kind
of just as a friend next time he reaches
out to be like
dude what the [__] are you doing you
this is embarrassing you look like a bum
well don't say a lot but yeah I'm I'm
confrontational
like as much as I know your [__] is
little this has been weighing on me for
a long time and I'm not even involved I
know I don't feel I don't feel
responsible for this
but I know that
I could potentially potentially have
some weight in the system yeah yeah yeah
yeah you need to figure your [__] out
um if I shouldn't if I should just stay
quiet that's you know got it whatever
but I just feel like
say something yeah none of them just
keep keep quiet I know financials are
hard to talk about true any advice you
guys can give me
I insert myself should I say something
should I stay should it be silent still
let her figure it out said that uh would
be really helpful like if I should say
something or
um so I think that
it does suck it's it your friend is
taking advantage of someone who's too
nice and unfortunately here's why it
sucks so much you you almost have to get
involved because you aren't it's not
like it's your fault that she's in this
situation but you help bring them
together and the fact is that she's
non-confrontational and someone needs to
confront this guy about the fact that he
hasn't paid
at all that's what I just said it's not
your fault yeah but like I get why she
feels inclined to say something I think
you're right that you should say
something now should you say the things
that you suggested you say absolutely
not what you should say is like look
you owe a lot of money to my cousin and
she's never going to confront you about
it and at this point it seems like you
know that and you're taking advantage of
that and like
I'm going to have to speak up on her
behalf she's very deeply troubled by
this and she's actually sought I mean
you don't want to maybe air out her [__]
but you can even say like
she's actually like had like her mental
Rings oh health issues crop up because
she's so stressed out about this like
what is going on why aren't you paying
your rent are you taking advantage of
her are you going through a hardship of
your own what is going on and you need
to start paying this back yeah this is
not working out I think that
um
first of all you'd at least have to get
involved so in so much that you have to
talk about this with your cousin at
length and at least get her
to commit to saying something if that
doesn't happen then say all right if
you're not going to say anything I want
to say right right yeah let me say
something yeah
and she said okay yeah yeah if she says
okay first of all this is weird this has
been happening for over a year and you
still even
I don't know I don't know the whole
thing but you still refer to this guy as
your friend that's [__] weird and so
shitty right if this guy's not if this
guy hasn't even brought it up it's just
like and if look if he's been like God
I'm so da da this has been as hard
if he's got some kind of reason of
course then it's different but if he's
just not paying her yeah then he's not
anyone's friend this guy's a [__]
villain
you know like it's possible that yes I'm
going to be shot this month or villain
yeah I'm sorry I'm going to show this
month I've been using my funds to try
and find Batman
I think that you need to uh definitely
ask that of your cousin yeah talk to
your cousin and then get involved yeah
if you're better at it and it's your
friend you got a shorthand with him he's
your best guy friend big yo bro it's
been over a year I just found out about
this recently what the [__] is going on
what's going on yeah this is illegal we
could take it to court this is [__] up
yeah stop taking advantage of my cousin
yeah you know she's so sweet she's not
gonna say anything I am yeah and by the
way your penis is one and a half inches
yeah and by the way
your dick is so small it literally sits
on top of your nut sack like a cherry on
top of a sundae now are you gonna pay or
are you not gonna pay yeah yeah
your penis literally is [__]
small
[Laughter]
that's a million degrees in here that's
cool yeah he is a billion billion
degrees so uh all right well maybe one
more yeah
made a movie but it was just because our
video was horizontal so now we're going
vertical oh cool we're both in it
all right go ahead babe Siamese uh she
struck himself right now or you'd like
some advice about is that our friends
um as we get older it seems like it's
harder to get together with our friends
than it used to be
um you know people get significant
others
change your tastes change so yes we
don't get to spend time it seems like
they only allocate
things or times socially
for like sports or like music events
that we just don't like care for yeah
yeah like our friends like Machine Gun
Kelly and we're just not
what should we do with these friends
like do we stay friends with them are we
just not gonna be friends with them
because we don't have the same interests
yeah yeah help us out thanks that is a
real cut them out thing okay well you
don't you don't have to be people's
friends you also don't need to cut them
out cut them out dude like a cancer you
don't need to be Machiavelli about it oh
you guys are a Cancer I'm cutting you
out leave a text message and then block
them no I think I think this is one of
the saddest things about getting older
than me really talks about it is friends
that you were
extremely tight with in your 20s let's
say yep by the time you're in your late
30s getting in your 40s you're just
you've drifted apart and it's not their
fault it's not your fault life happens
to people like you said their taste
changes their demeanor changes their
Outlook changes what they care about
changes and dude that's not it's
nobody's fault but you don't
here's the thing where people get into
trouble they've people feel like they
have to stay friends with people they've
been friends with hello resentment that
is [__] dude you don't owe anyone
anything if you're not friends with
someone hello resentment oops if you're
not friends with anyone someone anymore
you're just not in front of them it's
not your fault it's not their fault you
just aren't friends with them anymore
that's it it happens
ding dong oh look it's resentment why is
resentment why well I could start that
but why oh we got to go to this [__]
thing I don't want to go to this thing I
and then and I hate that [__] guy oh
oh well yeah he makes me go see [__]
uh puddle of Mud right my mind you're so
hung up on part of the mouth it was part
of the mud's main song again I don't
know Marco you know right ugly Ugly Kid
Joe remember that guy yes who's that
there's a different guy entirely yeah
they're the same guy probably no problem
is later than Ugly Kid Joe
oh thanks for not thanks for not looking
it up Anthony
can you sing it no say what it is uh
just say this sing it beautifully
say it
just what's it called yeah what's it I
don't remember oh okay well can you hum
it
blurry oh she hates me she hates me yeah
that's what it was She [__] Hates Me
isn't does he say She [__] Hates Me I
knew it that's I I know that kind of
stuff
[Music]
wow that is so 90s what was that dude
yeah wow dude 95 when was that let's see
you liked them oh dude two thousand yeah
I would have said that you had um
okay I would admit it if I did but I
didn't I had to dude I can't wait to
watch that video yeah yeah you know what
was my first CD ever you got it for me
what you don't know uh
hold on yeah Green Day dude
no not that album though no dookie was a
Long View Basket Case
um what were the other big ones and then
you also had um
God damn it what was that
what was that what was that band called
I don't remember what was it how'd it go
it was gold and black the CD case and it
was like a pyramid on it or something
golden black with a pure
was it
what kind of music I'm chasing oh
uh you know like that [__] same [__]
dude
oh The Offspring yup
what is it how did they go The Offspring
was uh
um she [__] likes me
the same yeah no all those songs were
like about how like I'm [__] loser
She [__] hates me uh it wasn't
Offspring The Offspring you did have but
there was another that's the one I had
the X-ray one yeah yeah but there was
another album that you had that was not
that that was gold and black
I'll never remember it I'll find it one
day but anyway
um Shane [__] feels okay about me a
different band wow
she's neither here nor there about me
she never met me
she doesn't know me there's probably a
girl somewhere just
guessing uh what was the [__]
question of the guy
well we said something was 90s friends
oh yeah yeah there's dookie yeah yeah I
would say cut him out though man yeah
it's cut them out but you don't need to
make a whole [__] show of it yeah
hold on don't worry about making it
don't tell them don't make a thing out
of it just like don't hang out with them
anymore man yo who cares and if they
come back and they're like hey what up
and just be like we don't like the same
things anymore man what do you want me
what do you want from me just be like
just be like hey dude point to me if
that happens I went and then when they
say what happened and your wife punches
really like
oh you know the worst end to a
friendship it was a horrible long weird
setup but I'm saying any points at you
but uh yeah dude friends here's the
thing if if an ex-friend makes you feel
bad about not being their friend anymore
bad person
worst therapist they don't understand
life and they're a bad person
worst guy running for office no I would
be president on that platform you
kidding me really yeah dude okay
um all right well thank you guys for
listening let's wrap this up so sorry
let's wrap this baby up it was a fun
episode because you know what it's a
thousand degrees in here it is a
thousand degrees in here and you can't
feel it but we can uh lifetime luxury go
over there there's a new episode two day
sign up for the patreon patreon.com
lifeline luxury and it's banging it's
just me and my brother [__] and it's
very fun and then uh you can come see me
I'm gonna be in Charlotte I'm gonna be
in Knoxville Little Rock Arkansas I'm
gonna be in uh Al Alberta I think ah
[__] Calgary whatever uh chrisley.com
get them tickets and then I got some new
crowd work videos up on my YouTube go to
the crystallia channel and check them
out
leave a uh video for us in the
description below and or you can call
the hotline if you want to be anonymous
and if you want a one-on-one section
with Matt session with Matt go to uh
mattelier.com and it'll help you with
different devices and besides that we've
got that killer merch going on so thank
you very much and appreciate you leave a
comment for the algorithm you know what
was your favorite 90s band huh or 2000.
name the [__] thing what was the
golden go to Black record that I was
trying to think of yeah help us out I'm
gonna look it up I don't know I don't
even have a guess I'm sure once I know
once I'm it wasn't like the craziest
it wasn't like the craziest popular band
but they were considered actually good
it wasn't just like puddle of Mud right
right right damn I want to know so help
us find it
also what's your favorite band help us
what's your favorite band and then 200
2000 wow idiot all right thank you guys
[Music]
hello